[Musique]
au nord-ouest des États-Unis au milieu
des montagnes de l'Oregon un village
tranquille et
propr c'est dans cette maison c que nous
rencontrons k 32 ans qui s'apprête à
prendre un tout nouveau départ elle a
pris une décision radicale dans quelques
jours elle quitter tout son confort pour
une aventure hor norme tu fais comment
pour le mettre au milieu c'est très bien
mais tu peux aller beaucoup plus vite
Katy va changé de vie elle est en train
d'équiper cette camionnette sa nouvelle
demeure avec l'aide de Travis qu'elle a
rencontré sur un forum elle s'apprête à
rejoindre une communauté qui ne cesse de
grandir aux États-Unis ceux qui larguent
tout pour vivre dans un fourgon
aménager
joli loin de la société de consommation
sa vie va désormais tenir dans cet
utilitaire ces nuits elle les passera
sur ce litamp on pas mais c'est vraiment
confortable pas de cuisine ni d'au
courante elle terminera l'aménagement de
sa camionnette en route avec les outil
qu'elle
emporté tout rentre dans ce panier c'est
un panier à
ou mais ça fait pas peur c'est un sacré
défi je sais pas ça va être un gros défi
c'est sûr je ser au milieu de nulle part
mais ça va être marrant ça va
aller
je suis vraiment fier d'elle elle est
très travailleuse elle a fait un travail
extraordinaire cet expert comptable a
choisi la liberté elle a mis un terme à
ses rêves de carrière de propriété de
croissance et de
consommation le truc essentiel c'est le
champoing sec elle a prévu d'emporter
dans ses valises le strict minimum une
petite révolution pour cette diplômée
habitué au confort d'une vie
bourgeoise
à l'université j'avais 100 paires de
chaussures c'était
absurde à cette époque je m' achetais
tout ce que je voulais pas 12 t-shirts
différents de toutes les
couleurs c'était tellement pas
nécessaire mon bonheur ne repose pas sur
ce que je possède c'est ce que j'ai
compris dans quelques jours elle sera
sur la route elle va rejoindre le grand
mouvement du van life en français la vie
en
camionnette le monde prendre la tangente
vagabondée et voyager toute l'année dans
des paysages sublimes les grands espaces
américains un décor de cinéma beaucoup
on rêvent mais eux ont sauté le pas
leurs photos donnent le vertige sur les
réseaux sociaux il génèent des millions
de clic et de dollars cette génération
de Nomad auto-entrepreneurs est ultra
connecté les vanliers veulent profiter
de la vie loin des exigences et des
contraintes de la société
contemporaine je ne me suis pas épilé
les jambes depuis un an et je n'y pense
pas
particulièrement il rêve de grands
espaces d'une vie en
autonomie peut-être que je suis naïve
mais je ne m'inquiète pas pour ma
sécurité cette quête de liberté attire
aussi des familles avec
enfants une are génération elle se dit
qu'elle peut vivre et travailler sur la
route profiter des voyages sans attendre
la retraite
faireaisir les seiors déjà grandsparents
ont eu aussi été piqués par le virus des
aventuriers qui cherchent le grand
frisson avec le confort de van de luxe
ce genre de situation l et moi c'est
vraiment ce qu'on
préfère un fourgon pour toute maison et
la route comme unique futur aux
États-Unis le phénomène van life prend
une ampleur phénoménale il serait des
dizaines de milliers avoir déjà fait ce
choix loin de tout tra de l'essentiel
tel est leur devise
sont-il en train de créer un nouveau
mode de
vie un nouveau rêve
[Musique]
américain chaque année c'est une ville
roulante etit qui s'installe dans une
plaine de l'oréon dans le nord-ouest des
États-Unis ça sent le van pas trs propr
venez nous voir on donner une bonne
douche il s'appelle ce sont ces
habitants des camionnettes pendant 3
jours un millier d'entre eux se
retrouvent pour faire une pause sur leur
route et partager leurs
expériences à 32 ans Coré et l'un de ses
voyageurs à pleintemps cela fait 6 ans
qu'il est sur la route cet ancien guide
de kayak est l'un des pionniers du
mouvement salut comment ça va ils n'ont
pas l'air comme ça mais avant de tout
larguer ils avaient une vie plus
conventionnel ici tu rencontres des gens
qui n'ont pas plus de 20 dollars en
poche et d'autres qui vivent dans des
vannes qui coûtent 200000
dollars il n'y a pas de profil
typ tu peux avoir des hip assis à côté
d'un officier de
carrière leur icône c'est ce célèbre
camion des années 60 le Combi Volkswagen
le symbole vintage de leur vie
nomade un habitat que ses propriétaires
adap au gr de leur
pérégrination poil dans ton van je peux
le voir oui il est
là-bas il marche hyper bien et ne prend
pas beaucoup de place et ton but c'est
de vivre à la montagne tout l'hiver oui
je serai dans le Colorado pour faire du
snowboard ça devrait me tenir
[Musique]
chaud on les retrouve sur Instagram fier
de leur nouvelle vie dans un cadre
toujours
enchanteur il y a lise une ancienne
présentatrice de journaux télévisés qui
vit désormais dans unam
Britan et son petit am qui vendait des
montres de luxe avant de partir sur la
route
ou encore David un ingénieur en réseau
électrique qui gagnait 80000 € par an et
qui a tout plaqué pour faire de
l'escalade au 4 coin de
l'Amérique un choix qui n'est pas
toujours facile à faire accepter par
leur
[Musique]
entourage Asel
et tes parents ils en pensent quoi oh
mes
parents ma mère n'en a aucune idée elle
flipperait tout le temps mais tu sais il
faut juste franchir le pas et se lancer
dans l'aventure même si tes parents et
tes potes disent que c'est stupide de
quitter
l'école avec ses amis Coré cultive le
goût de l'aventure hors des sentiers
battus comment ça va ça va et toi il a
contribué à faire connaître Mouv grce à
son blog avec ses photos de voyage qui
conna un succès
grandissant tout le monde connait son
blog et tu sais tu peux devenir une
célébrité sur Instagram mais Coré n'a
jamais pris la grosse tête il est hyper
abordable vas-y
continue le site qu'ilanime est suivi
par près de 200000
personnes avecte
am
ch à profiter de le notoriéé pour
toucher un public JEE sur les réseaux
sociaux les vanlu comme parviennent à
vivre de leur image financer le vie
nom malgré les apparen de CO il n' pas
perdu le sens des
[Musique]
affaires
quelques semaines plus tard nous
retrouvons Coré dans le M l'un des États
les plus sauvages d'Amérique au nord de
New
[Musique]
York sa petite amie
Émilie était responsable
marketing avant de devenir un business
le vanl se veut une philosophie du
voyage minimaliste et respectueuse de
[Musique]
l'environnement
de
courge tournesol on peut
rajouteront explorer l'état d'umain
pendant 10
jours avant chaque départ ils font
toutes leur cours dans des coopératives
bio un petit sacrifice car le budget est
limité
pistach bon c'est un peu
cher ach du BI pour moi
ce n'est pas seulement se nourrir mieux
avec de bons
légumes c'est aussi faire attention à
notre
planète ils achètent tout en vra en
utilisant ces boîtes pour limiter les
emballages
259 une vingtaine d'euros pour quelques
jours de vivre presque pas de dépens de
l'amour et de l'eau fraîche chaque jour
il voyage sur la route en décidant
souvent leur destination à la dernière
minute mais avant de partir ils vont
réaliser une photo car au pays du van
life l'esthétique est primordiale pour
espérer gagner de l'argent je vais
sortir les
chiens ils ont choisi ce cadre idylique
au bord de la
mer parfait une marque les P près de
1000 € par mois pour s'afficher
régulièrement avec ce thermos sur leur
compte
Instagram cette entreprise nous aide à
financer nos voyages à être en mesure de
partager nos expériences ligne avec
notre
public si c'était juste pour l'argent on
ne ferait pas ça on est pas riche vous
savez oui c'est vraiment pour vivre
notre
aventure et ça nous aide sur le plan
financier mais on aurait vraiment du mal
à vivre dans un appartement ou une
maison avec l'argent qu'on
gagne les marques sont prêtes à les
payer car ces deux modèles amateurs sont
très doués pour jouer de leur image
tu aimes bien cette photo il passe des
heures à choisir et à retoucher les
[Musique]
clichés je la trouve un peu jaune en
arrièreplan chacune de leurs photos de
rêve attire des milliers de clics 3000
en tout pour celleci cela ressemble à
des vacances mais pour eu c'est un
travail à part
entière N pasintérê s je pour s'acheter
une maison et on pouvait pas se le
permettre et donc on a décidé de faire
différemment et on s dit que serait plus
sympa de
voyager mais c'est clair qu'on rejette
pas la société
capitaliste non onessie pas d'échapper
au
travail il est clair pour nous que la
vie c'est du boulot et que c'est pas
toujours
rose
en moyenne à eux deux il gagnent un peu
plus de 2000 € par mois mais il ne
dépense presque
rien il y en a pour 2h
de pour les prochains jours ils ont
décidé d'aller découvrir un sommet de la
région la fin de l'automne leur offre
des paysages sublimes mais Émilie ne
lâche jamais son téléphone une marque de
bière vient de leur proposer un nouveau
contrat écoute ça ne me convient pas je
ne sais pas vraiment si on doit
s'impliquer
là-dedans c'est pas vraiment en accord
avec nos valeurs
ouais tu vois là on va dire non à un
contrat de 2400 dollars pour trois
photos Émilie enregistre tout leur vie
sur les réseaux sociaux est devenue une
source de revenu une façon de financer
leur choix
Nomad allez on y va sur la route ils
sont libres de leur temps libre d'aller
où bon leur semble quand ils veulent à
l'heure où toute l'Amérique se met au
travail c'est superbe ici eux partent en
excursion oui c'est vraiment le moment
idéal il y a de la neige partout mais
encore des feuilles sur les
arbres 3h de balade et au sommet Émilie
et Coré sont récompensés de leurs
efforts un endroit idéal pour une
photo tu vas être
trempé je le suis déjà
la lumière du soir est idéal parfait
pour faire rêver leurs abonnés la VAN
attitude se vit et se poste
frénétiquement
Bella regarde-moi
là le cliché rapidement apprécié par
2400 internautes contribuent à leur
renommée c'est ce que cherchent les
annonceur qui les
contacte le soir venu ils installent
leur campement dans le parc national
Émilie et Coré auront toute la forêt
pour eux seul cette
nuit nous sommes dans la forêt d'un parc
national dans le New Hampshire des
forêts comme ça il y en a dans tous les
États-Unis et ils autorise le camping
sauvage vous pouvez rester jusqu'à 14
jours c'est gratuit et c'est
magnifique en 6 ans Émilie et Coré ont
appris à vivre simplement avec moins de
60 € par jour dans le
nire comment vous faites pour cuisiner
dans ce petit
espace c'est un peu le bazar j'en mets
un peu
partout toujours dans ces
cas là il y a des pelures d'oignon des
morceaux
d'oignons des traces de gras un peu
partout donc c'est un peu compliqué mais
tu peux y
arriver
cor le dîner est
prêt à la
tienne ce soir il fait 0 degr Milie a
les pieds encore trempés mais il garde
le
sourire à partir du moment où vous avez
les bons vêtements et les bons sacs de
couchage ça peut
aller et les deux chiens et les
dei Penny
dégage fais-moi de la place je suis
fatiguée allez
péni leor viux van est très mal isolé
les chiens serviront de
[Musique]
radiateur comme presque chaque matin le
couple se réveille dans un écrain de
verdure Émilie s'est levé la première
pour aller
[Musique]
méditer comme chez moi dans mon élément
je me sens comme si j'étais un petit
enfant cette liberté qui me rappelle mes
ans quand j'allais courir dans les bois
et que je jouais dans mon jardin
secret depuis 6 ans Émilie commence
toutes ses journées comme ça ce qui
était impossible dans sa vie d'avant
elle affirme que son rapport au corps et
à la féminité échappe aujourd'hui au
code imposé par la
société
en vivant dans un van j'ai libéré la
femme sauvage qui était en moi j'ai
arrêté d'accorder de l'importance à ce
que les gens pensaient de moi et ça a
commencé par quelque chose d'aussi
simple que d'arrêter de m'épiler les
jambes j'ai commencé à me sentir plus à
l'aise avec ce que mon corps est
naturellement la personne que je
suis et donc oui jeis depis un an et je
n'y pense même
pas ces Paes inspirées dans des cadres
sublimes sont très suivis sur internet
mais ce qui a contribué à sa notoriété
elle en est bien consciente ce sont ces
photos dénudé qu'elle poste sans
complexe souvent avec les produits d'une
marque comme le fameux thermos qui la
paye à chaque
publication oui c'est vrai que ça attire
plus de CC donc il y a un côté business
idment c'est un business vous savez j'ai
étudié le marketing donc je comprends
que ça génère plus de vu sur internet
mais je ne vois rien de mal à cela parce
que ce n'est pas en contradiction avec
ce que je
suis cool mais pragmatique avec le sens
des affaires elle assume sa
stratégie c'est à ce prix qu'elle peut
continuer cette vie qu'elle
n'abandonnerait pour rien au
monde Ky est encore loin de cette
routine dans la maison familiale de
l'Oregon la jeune voyageuse solo va
prendre la route elle va quitter ses
parents qui sont très mal à l'aise face
au choix de leur filles tu es prête à
partir prête à partir je suis un peu
inquiète de savoir toujours seul dans le
van ils ont fait fortune dans
l'industrie et ne comprennent pas le
projet de Katy loin de leur rêve à
eux c'est un virage à 180°gr pour
elle il y a quelques années elle
habitait un appartement de standing elle
dirigeait un bureau
fraîchement diplômé de la fac elle a
acheté une maison dans l'Oregon pour la
rénover
elle jardina elle a même refait la
cuisine
avit plein de
projets et puis elle a cette
idée moi je trouve pas ça
normal s douche sans
toil
je suis super têtu mais ça me touche
qu'il s'inquiète pour
moi moi je ne pense pas fuir je cherche
juste à faire ce qui me rend
heureuse on l'a fait trop
[Rires]
indépendante fais attention à
toi ok
ok à l'opposé de cette vie toute tracée
elle a décidé de partir au moins un an
voir plus si l'expérience est
concluante dans son voyage en quête du
bonheur elle n'emporte qu'une petite
valise et sa chienne Sophie c'est parti
[Musique]
elle n'a pas d'itinéraire précis Katy a
rassemblé toutes ses économies 25
pendant son voyage elle espère gagner ce
dont elle a besoin en travaillant comme
photographe pour des mariages elle verra
bien je suis super excitée je suis comme
une gosse à la veille de la
rentrée c'est vraiment un changement de
vie je vais créer une maison et chaque
jour sera une expérience
différente vivre seul dans une
camionnette sans isolation sans confort
un saut dans l'inconnu pour cet ancien
cadre tu peux jamais savoir si tu es
dans un endroit sécurisé pour passer la
nuit c'est l'un des
inconvénients pour sa première nuit elle
a demandé à son ami Trevis de
l'accompagner il la précède dans son
fourgon il y a plusieurs chemins ici sur
lesquels on peut s'aventurer et explorer
oui je suis là c'est un bon endroit pour
s'arrêter des routes de terre désertes
au milieu de la forêt à 1 heure au moins
du village le plus proche
désormais c'est dans ce genre d'endroit
isolé qu'elle passera ces nuitjà
arriv en attendant d'avoir une cuisine
dans le van de son
ami tu es enfin sur la route
félicitation d' être arrivé
là merci pour ton aide tu sais pour mon
premier voyage le sol était à peine
terminé et j'avais juste un qui pend
entre de MS je l'idée de me réveiller
demain au milieu de nulle
part un lit de camp et un sac de
couchage un peu léger pour supporter le
froid
elle n'a pas tout prévu et va découvrir
la vie van life de façon
[Musique]
brutale le soleil se lève sur la vallée
de
et pour sa prière nuit Katy n'a pas
beaucoup
dormi ce matin j'ai froid à 4 ou 5h du
matin je me suis réveillé j'étais
gelé à 1200 m d'altitude les
températures ont atteint 5 de pas de
douche désormais elle va devoir se
contenter d'eau gelée et de shampoing
sec mais c'est ce qu'elle est venu
[Musique]
chercher
quand tu te réveilles et que tu
n'entends que le bruit de l'eau c'est si
paisible
j'adore c'est un style de vie différent
qui je pense te donne plus de chance de
t'élever personnellement tu n'es pas
sollicité en
permanence par les réseaux sociaux
donc cette force a profité du monde
extérieur et de la
nature ce nouveau style de vie qui
séduit de plus en plus d'Américains a
fait exploser le marché du van de loisir
il est aujourd'hui en pleine croissance
plus de 10 % par an aux
États-Unis à fren au centre de la
Californie un entrepreneur passionné en
profite
pleinement comment ça va ça va merci
Johnny est dans l'arrière boutique je
pense oui Alan Feld a fait fortune en
aménageant des camionnettes de luxe avec
son fils Johnny comment tu vas mec ça va
super vous avez l' occupé oui on a pas
mal de
boulot la société des feldes a été créée
dans les années 60 c'est la plus
ancienne des États-Unis dans ce domaine
aujourd'hui elle réalise plusieurs
millions de dollars de chiffre
d'affaires les clients viennent de tout
le pays pour leur commander des
camionnettes sur
mesure regarde la tablette est retenue
par un petit aim et elle se détache
comme
ça c'est
superbe pour communiquer sur touteses
options d'aménagement la société cré des
vidéos qui sont V des milliers de fois
sur
Internet pouvez VO qu'il
ymée de ce van la partie couchage
dispose d'une vue à 360
de on peut tout voir autour et le siège
du passager peut même se
[Musique]
retourner bonjour je suis Joë comment
allez-vous aujourd'hui bien je suis
Daniel bonjour je suis
Maria on a regardé sur YouTube
Instagram on pense vivre
pleintemps on VI en Californie et on
cherche à changer de
vie il faudra vendre notre maison mais
comme ça on sera plus
libre ici tout est possible on peut vous
installer une salle de bain de 83 cm de
large même à plus de 100000 € ce couple
semble déjà emballé alors vousêtes prê
renoncer au confort de votre salle de
main petit à petit on s'est laissé
convaincre le voyage c'est l'argument
principal
oui parce qu'on a commencé dans la vie
avec une maison avec deux
chambres ensuite on a déménagé dans une
maison avec quatre chambres mais on a
cette envie de voyager alors on s'est
dit pourquoi pas
emmener la maison alors on veut juste
vendre notre maison et tous nos biens et
s'installer dans un van
chaque camion est aménagé sur mesure les
clients peuvent demander les options les
plus folles comme pour ce van il y en a
pour 6000 dollars rien qu'en
sonorisation là tu as des enceintes au
plafond le sonby surround une télé 50
cm et c'était quoi les demandes les plus
folles un mec voulait une barre de un
autre une station de pêche sur glace on
a d perer un trou dans le van pour me
puisse se garer au milieu d'un lac gelé
pêcher avec le chauffage allumé je suis
pas sûr que c'était une bonne idée un
véhicule de 5 tonnes au milieu de la
glace imaginez si c'est légal on le fera
si c'est illégal faut qu'on en parle et
on vous fera pas de facture c'est
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
tout au qu coins des États-Unis les Van
rivalisent de bricolage et d'imagination
pour construire la maison roulante la
plus attrante ou la plus
pratique a le genre caravane en bois
massif le van façon salon
bourgeois l'option cuisine
démontable la salle de sport déployable
ou même le cinéma
ambulant aujourd'hui Alan va découvrir
leur dernière création wou c'est
magnifique j'adore la
peinture un van de ha standing en fibre
de verre avec peinture inréable il y en
a pour s 70000 € le prix d'une petite
maison la boîte de vitesse a deux
leviers tu peux passer en 4 roue motrice
gamme basse ou gamme haute ou deux roues
avantmotrices c'est un véhicule de
l'extrême pour le toutterrain
l'équivalent d'un véhicule de l'armée
mais en version
aménagée ces derniers temps la
production est débordée une centaine de
camions aménager et un carnet de
commande plein pour les mois à venir du
jamais
vu salut comment ça va bravo pour ton
bébé merci merci il va falloir lui
offrir un
van tout est plein jusqu'au 16 septembre
2019 avant on en assemblé TR ou qu par
semaine maintenant c'est plus 4 5 si par
semaine donc ça
progresse vous pensez qu'Instagram les
réseaux ont contribué à cet
essort Instagram et les réseaux sociaux
n'ont pas fait de mal c'est sûr ces 5
dernières années les Vanes sontevenu
populaires et branch grâce à un
mouvement van
life à 60 ans Alan a transmis
l'entreprise à son fils désormais lui
aussi passe le plus clair de son temps à
voyager devant son immense Villain son
van 44 est toujours prêt à partir il
garde sa maison pour recevoir ses petits
enfants quand lui et sa femme reviennent
de
[Musique]
virer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais qui est
là comment vous avez fait pour devenir
si
grande les filles vous allez venir
camper avec nous non non vous allez
rester
ici 2 ans et Olivia 4 ans ne voi plus
que très rarement leurs grands-parents
les de jeunes retraités passent les tr/
de leur temps sur la
route
le plus dur quand on est constamment en
train de bouger et de voyager c'est que
nos petites filles nous
manquent donc on rentre toutes les 4 5
semaines pour les
voir Johnny a dû se faire à l'idé qu'à
60 ans ses parents avaient une envie de
prendre le large à la moindre
occasion c'est top ce qu'ils font je
suis même un peu jaloux je veux partir
et vivre dans un van mais moi je suis
bloqué avec les enfants ir de bureau
avec toutes ces obligations je ne suis
pas libre d'aller où je veux ouais je
suis un peu
envieux et bien écoute tu as qu'à faire
comme nous je veux être un bon exemple
pour mes enfants on a travaillé
extrêmement dur pendant 30 ou 40 ans tu
sais parfois on travailler 90 jours
d'affilé pendant les expositions de Van
cette vie c'est le fruit d'un travail
acharné je pense qu'ils peuvent le
comprendre
ouais mais perdre no babysit c'est dur
à chaque départ c'est la même chose les
petites filles d'alanise n'arrivent pas
à laisser partir leurs
grands-parents ok gros
bisous ré que voustez oui c
[Musique]
comprend le couple part quelques
semaines s'échapper en
Californie ils vont voyager à leur
manière dans van à 150000 € avec des
aménagements dignes d'une
limousine une des choses qu'on prend
sans faute c'est notre petit bar des
pliants on a notre vin français
là-dedans on vit dans un van 4at roues
motrices dans des conditions extrêmes
mais on aime nos équipements de
luxe on emporte aussi beaucoup
d'équipements de
survie on a une hache une fusée de
détresse
des chaînes des câbles de
remorquage vous n'êtes pas un V
ordinaire ah non ça non on va là où la
plupart des Vanes ne vont
[Musique]
pas rouler dans les endroits les plus
extrêmes c'est ça qui attire cet expert
de la conduite en
van bonjour bienvenue au parc Yosémite
bonjour bienvenue dans les montagnes
merci ils partent traverser un grand
parc national américain le Yosémite qui
fait la taille d'un département
[Musique]
français ça vous fait quoi d'être à
nouveau sur la route oh
j'adore je me sens bien c'est bien mieux
que d'être à la maison devant la
télé des routes tortueuses parfois même
dangereuses
au détour d'un virage un accident vient
de se produire ça va vous allez
bien ces touristes indiens ont percuté
un rocher avec leur
voiture ils ont de la chance avec les
airag qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé qu'est-ce que c'est c'est du
fromage encore sous le choc la passagère
s'en sort avec une brûlure au front et
un poignet tordu mais alan est conscient
que son mode de vie peut l'exposer à de
nombreux dangers dans quelques heures le
couple sera livré à lui-même loin de la
civilisation ça pe vraiment mal tourner
si tu nes pas préparé nous on a
plusieurs trous de secours fait par des
médecins avec de quoi recoudre des
PL car si ce genre d'accident se produit
dans la Vallée de la Mort tu peux
attendre 3 à 4 He avant que les secours
n'arriv en plus le nom de notre van
c'est Rapha c'est un ange
gardien
al repart car le meilleur reste à voir
avant la tombée de la
nuit le parc du Yosémite avec ses milli
de lac et de cours d'eau forêt de cèdre
qui abrit des ours
brun regarde
tellement avec son 44p par à l'assaut
d'un col
périlleux ici pas de réseau mobile pas
de secours alors Alan reste très
concentré sur sa
conduite ça va être
dur attends attends tu vas beaucoup trop
vite là à mon goût je vais essayer en le
prenant d'un autre angle laisse-mo
regarder jeis vérifier attends attends
mais attends attends non non mais c'est
bon je sors
là il s'engage avec précaution guidé par
sa
copilote le passage est délicat mais pas
de quoi effrayer ses retraités devenu
expert dans les rallyis de
montagne je suis au top je reste en
forme je fais du sport tout le
temps je vais leur montrer aux jeunes
que les vieux aussi peuvent s'amuser
ce qu'on est en train de faire là l et
moi on s'éclate on adore faire
ça après une journée de route ils
s'enfonce sur ce chemin inaccessible à
la plupart des véhicules ils vont
s'arrêter
là dans cette plain sauvage au milieu
des
montagnes il n'y a personne à moins de
km le bonheur pour le couple qui
installe en de de un restaurant avec une
vue impr un menu digne d'une table
étoilée on va manger du thon rouge cuit
en aller-retour avec une sauce au wasabi
et au soja accompagné d'un riz aux
oignons et aux champignons avec des
courgettes
grillées et pour sublimer le tout un bon
vin
français ça n'a pas l'air très pratique
vous ne seriez pas mieux chez
vous oui mais je n'ai pas cette de vue
dans ma
maison le coucher de soleil qu'il y a
juste là jusqu'au lever demain matin ça
fait partie de l'aventure et on est là
pour ça et puis quand on campe on a faim
tout le temps alors nos plats paraissent
bien
meilleurs santé santé chérie le couple
campe et voyage en amoureux depuis plus
de 40 ans eux aussi ont été vanliers
sans le sous quand on était plus jeune
et qu'on campait on m des hot dog des
hamburgers des
chips maintenant qu'on
vieillit et bien on ve manger plus car
on veut faire ça pendant longtemps
encore ces nouveau Nomad ont fait du
voyage un élixir de
jouvance c'est la liberté je me sens
libéré des contraintes
matérielles j'ai pas besoin de C j'ai
pas besoin de ça dans le van j'ai juste
le
nécessaire une nuit dans la nature comme
luxe
ultime il y a les moments magiques et
les jours de pluie moins drôle le van
tout d'un coup quand on est coincé dans
un habitacle de poche retour sur la
côteest
avecies internet qui ont choisi de
dormir ce soir dans un vrai lit à
l'abri vous êtes
trempé vous êtes
[Musique]
trempé Maria la merère de Corée les
accueille dans le confort de sa maison
bien chauffée malgré leur vie nomade le
couple tient à maintenir des liens forts
avec la famille et les
amis même si ce sont de grands enfants
des adultes on est vraiment content de
les avoir à la maison on prend des
nouvelles d'ux de leurs chiens ce sont
de vrais bons
moments et en plus ce sont de très bon
cuisinier pour nous c'est essentiel de
revenir régulièrement dans la région où
on a grandi et de se retrouver avec
notre famille c'est une sensation qu'on
ne peut pas trouver sur la
route je sais ce qu'il manque de la noix
de muscade oh vraiment
entre deux voyages Coré et Émilie
restent parfois soufflés ici plusieurs
semaines en profitant de la générosité
de leurs
parents au début quand ils nous ont
annoncé leur nouvelle vie on savait pas
combien de temps ça allait durer mais on
les supporte totalement parce qu'ils ont
réussi à construire un projet et faire
ce qui leur
plaît on continue à les voir et à faire
partie de leur vie parfois on les
retrouve même sur la route et on partage
un bout de leur aventure on se sent
vraiment très reconnaissant d'avoir des
parents aussi
compréhensif bon je dois financer mon
fils alors je vais bosser demain
qu'estce que vous avez
dit non mais c'est pas vrai il faut pas
que ça soit dans le film c'est pas
[Rires]
vrai demain ils reprendront la route
cette nuit ils dormiront au chaud et au
sec
[Musique]
cette vie de voyage de plus en plus de
coup avec enfants la tente aujourd'hui
aux États-Unis ils n'ont pas peur de se
lancer sur les routes en famille c'est
ce qu'on fait les fit au nord de la
Floride dans la famille il y a le père
Lamar la maman
achelé le chien beouth et enfin une
petite fille de 4 ans ils ont bâti un
petit studio roulant avec un grand lit
pour les parents et une couchette à part
pour leur enfant qui apprend à compter
en
voyageant 1 2
3 nous avons décidé de vivre en van
après avoir fait un voyage dans 47 état
du
pays nous avons fait ce voyage dans une
petite voiture et après on s'est dit que
ce serait quand même
il y a 2 ans ils ont vendu leur maison
pour s'offrir ce camion ils ont
participé à une émission de télé réalité
le concept des couples comme eux se font
filmer à chaque étape de la construction
de leur nouveau
logement je suis l et je suis
nousen et nous suivons la dernière
tendance vivre dans un logement de poche
et acheter une camionnette on aé les
côtés nerveuse pour tenir les délais ok
parfait il nous reste beaucoup à faire
dans un délai très
[Musique]
réduit dans leur
van tout est calculé au millimè près
chaque matin après avoir habiller leur
filles ils doivent ranger leur
[Musique]
maison chaque chose a un emplacement
précis c'est comme ça que je l'ai
dessiné pour la plupart des objets je
savais déjà où il devait se
ranger pour faire rentrer toutes les
affaires de la famille les fit ont fait
preuve d'ingéniosité il y a des placards
partout jusque sous les
planchers on se partage tous les trois
ce rangement ici deux petites boîtes à
jouer en s'installant dans le van on a
établi une règle avec ma fille ce qui ne
rentre pas dans ses boîtes elle ne peut
pas les garder et quand on va dans un
magasin de jouet elle se débrouille
toujours pour en trouver de
dit maman ça ça peut rentrer dans notre
van les journées du couple sont elles
aussi très organisées ils ont trouvé un
travail en adéquation avec la vie qu'ils
ont choisi une marque de boisson les
emploie pour conduire ses camions
publicitaires et installer des
animations à travers tout le pays c'est
à ce prix qu'ils peuvent financer chacun
de leur voyage monte ici on va y aller
ok regarde il a un
renard viens on va retrouver ta
babysitter dans la ville d'à côté on y
va d'accord
ok à chaque étape du voyage les parents
doivent trouver quelqu'un pour garder
leur fille
Everly ça c'est vraiment une galère dans
la vie en van comme on a pas de maison
pour accueillir la babysitter tous les
jours on doit enner notre fille Chezelle
en plus on travaille dans deux ou tris
endroits différents dans une même
journée grâce à une application
sélectionne des babysitter de la région
en se fiant aux recommandations laissé
par d'autres
mamans
on est arrivé ma chérie la petite
everley est habitué à changer de nounou
chaque semaine et ses parents ont tout
prévu pour qu'elle se sente chez elle
hello rentre comment ça va tu as apporté
ton vélo mais c'est génial est-ce qu'on
va aller à la plage vous avez toujours
sa crème solaire n'est-ce pas oui madame
ok parfait qu'est-ce que je t'aime viens
là que je te fasse un
câlin amuse-toi
bien merci
beaucoup à plus tard amuse-toi bien
ça va aller pour elle elle est habitué
elle dit juste ok ok au revoir maman tu
peux
partir av plus capricie jamais il aur pu
choisir de mener cette
vie coup instant des stand de promotion
pour des marques toute l'année ce jourl
il do monter et installer un présentoir
dans un cadre pe
reluisant je vais demander àintérieur o
on doit sinstaller une station service
en bordure
d'autoroute il monent des stands
plusieurs fois par jour là c'est une
marque de bière qui a fait appel à leur
service 1 2
3 attends attends l'autre jour je me
suis retourné le poignet et du coup
j'utilise ce gant parce que c'est
vraiment trop
lourd quelques heures plus tard le
couple va démonter le stand pour
l'installer dans un super marché à eux
deux il gagnent 1800 € par mois pour ses
deux diplômés cette vie de manœuvre et
le prix à payer pour garder leur
liberté ce n'est pas pour ça que je suis
allé à l'école
évidemment mais c'est un moyen idéal
pour voyager et travailler en voyant du
pays après le boulot les fit ont
récupéré leurs
filles cela fait des mois qu'ils
parcourent l'intérieur du pays ils vont
enfin pouvoir fouler le sable de Floride
[Musique]
on doit aller voir la
mer tu crois qu'elle est froide qu'elle
est chaudeelle est juste
parfaite on y est
enfin c'est vraiment génial je suis cont
d'être ici cet endroit çare mais pour
lesis à
venir
des parc nationau pour se garer
gratuitement mes Amam l'une des villes
les plus ch d'Amérique ne sait pas très
bien comment trouver un emplacement pour
la
nuit donc j'ai fait des recherches avant
de venir on aime improviser mais on aime
bien s'organiser à l'avance
aussi et le plus gros problème auquel on
a été confronté c'est que Miami est
l'une des villes les plus difficiles
d'Amérique pour les campurs comme
nous iction d'endroit où l'on ne peut
pas se garer ici rien n'est
gratuit ce soir pas de vue sublime sur
la plage ni de coucher de soleil posté
sur internet il n'y a pas de place ici
c'est la réalité moins glamour de leur
vie nomade faute d'emplacement libre la
famille termine sur le parking d'un
centre commercial mais même ici ils ne
sont pas toujours les bienvenus avec
leur van il y a un panneau
d'interdiction pour les campeurs
oui le gros problème c'est qu'il n'y a
jamais de panneau d'interdiction pour
les vannes d'habitude et là il y en a un
pour la première
fois il a un monsieur qui arrive en
voiture juste derrière
nous il arrive je crois qu'il veut te
parler cette Z elle est interdite au
stationnement merci Monsieur c'est bien
compris la famille est épuisée
plutôt que de chercher un emplacement
toute la nuit ils vont casser leur
tirliire une centaine de dollars pour
passer une nuit tranquille dans un
motel ils ont accepté ce travail pour
pouvoir vivre de nouvelles expériences
et être sans
attache dès le jour suivant ils ont
prévu de partir à la découverte des plus
belles plages de
[Musique]
Floride à l'autre bout du pays au milieu
du désert de Moab dans le Colorado
nous retrouvons ktiy la voyageuse
solitaire avec sa chienne
Sophie depuis son départ il y a 2 mois
elle a déjà parcouru 6000 km au volant
de son
camion je me sens beaucoup plus à l'aise
que lorsque j'ai
commencé quand je suis parti mon van
n'était pas construit il avait
rien je ne savais pas où trouver du
courant
maintenant j'apends toujours mais tout
est plus
Simp travers le parc national des arches
150 km de route Milie formation
naturell
magnifique quand on voites montagnes
im à côté moi et mon van on est
minuscule
comme prévu elle bricole sa maison en
route en ce moment elle fait les
dernières finitions sur les lates de son
plafond débile à
reconnaîre pas mal de
gensol il pens t que j'étais en
couple il ne pens pas qu'une fille pit
faire ça toute
seule terminé le lit pliable désormais
se P le luxe d'un matelas King Siiz
comme chaque nuit Katy a établi son
campement au milieu de nulle part sans
s'inquiéter d'éventuell mauvais
rencontre je n'ai pas cette
inquiétude mes parents s'inquiètent
parce que je suis leur
enfant mais par chance je n'ai pas eu de
problème jusqu'à
présent peut-être que je suis naïve mais
je n'ai pas
peur dans son fourgon elle n'a pas
encore de radiateur ni même de
réchaud par 0 degr elle se contentera
d'un repas
froid une vie d'assette et de solitude
en quittant tout c'est exactement ce
qu'elle
[Musique]
recherchait quand j'ai décidé de me
lancer j'étais célibataire donc c'était
facile je n'avais aucune
attache est-ce que vous pensez
rencontrer quelqu'un sur la
route pense pas je ne cherche pas trop
[Musique]
ça au réveil elle doit prendre la route
pour aller se
laver pour sa toilette elle a pris un
abonnement dans un réseau de salle de
sport connu elle va se débarbouiller au
milieu des sportifs dans les toilettes
des
vesties
vous n'avez pas l'impression d'être une
s domicile fix dans ce
moment je ne pense pas ça fait juste
partie d'un style de vie
différent et quand je peux je fais aussi
du sport plutô que juste prendre une
douche
repartir je me lave les cheveux deux
fois par semaine et je prends une douche
peutêtre fois par
semaine pour mes cheveux quand tu es en
ville tu les laves tout le temps et tu
le laisses pas le temps de
respirer Katy ressemble beaucoup moins à
la jeune fille bourgeoise qui a quitté
ses parents il y a 2
mois ses copines sont les premières
étonnées par le
changement à l'aéroport de Denver elle
vient chercher lin une amie proche oh
mon dieu je vais
pleurer
c'est dingue tu dors làdedans tu
cuisines et tu c'est trop génial
pourquoi est-ce que je fais pas ça
est-ce que je peux me joindre à toi pour
le reste de ton tour ouais sérieux
faisant ça j'arrive pas à croire que je
suis
là contrairement à elle sa copine l vit
dans une
maison elle essaie de comprendre le
choix du nouveau style de vie de son
ami qu'est-ce qui est le plus dur quand
tu vis dans un
van le fait de ne pas avoir de gazère
parce que tu ne peux pas cuisiner
oui j'ai passé mon temps à manger des
avocats et des
[Rires]
bananes tu trouves ça cool ou un peu
angoissant parce que tu dois toujours
savoir où aller et
cetera non c'est pas stress s chaque
jour est différent il n'y a pas de
routine et c'est ce que je voulais
jusque- là tout a été
positif je pense que tout le monde en a
envie il faut vraiment le
vivre pour passer outre tous les petits
tracas par exemple ne pas pouvoir faire
du café le matin ça me rendrait
folle après seulement quelques semaines
sur les routes elle n'est déjà plus
certaine de vouloir redevenir sédentaire
un jour
en Floride la famille fit par explorer
l'qu un magnifique chap d' lar de
Miami un bien mérité avec petit budget
Sy et en gardant toujours le
[Musique]
sour on pourrait facilement se
plaindre je suis pvre je me douche dans
des
paring je vais rentrer sans permission
dans ce stade municipal pour aller me
doucher et ça c'est vraiment marrant et
donc on essaie de se mettre dans un état
d'esprit où tout est
rigolo c'est le plus grand océan que
j'ai jamais vu
oui je sais c'est fou regarde l'eau est
turquoise pour ces quelques jours de
vacances ils se sont offert un petit
plaisir ce camping avec une magnifique
vue sur la
baie
il y a de l'eau partout où l'on regarde
tu le
vois oui il y a de l'eau partout à
l'horizon depuis que la famille a vendu
sa maison il y a 3 ans chaque jour il
faut faire la cuisine sur une petite
gazinière de
camping mais ils assument très bien ce
style de vie nomade plus en phase avec
le monde moderne selon
eux
notre génération elle dit je peux
travailler sur la route et voyager et je
peux voir toutes les choses
merveilleuses qu'il y a avoir avant de
prendre ma retraite parce que nous
n'avons pas le temps parce que nous ne
savons pas si on vivra assez longtemps
pour profiter de notre retraite ou
d'être en assez bonne santé pour en
profiter alors autant le faire
maintenant et pour l'école les parents
utilisent les nouvelles technologies à 4
ans Everly n'a jamais connu de classe
maternelle une application lui sert
d'instituteur regarde maman très bien
bravo si tu termines tout le programme
de la première section de maternelle tu
auras droit à un gâteau unete au
citron je pense qu'il y a beaucoup
d'avantag à s'impliquer dans l'éducation
de ses
enfants et ça c'est plus compliqué quand
vous avez un travail de
bureau et que vous ne passez pas
beaucoup de temps avec vos enfants
j'ai des amis qui font ça très bien mais
pour nous cette vie nous correspond
beaucoup
[Musique]
mieux cet après-midi au programme les
EAU transparentes de
l'archipel 4 jours de travail pour 3
jours de vacances c'est comme ça qu'il
vivent toute l'année il prenarge vers la
baie de Floride Lam va plonger pour la
tout prière fois de il a négocié un bon
prix avec un pêcheur du
[Musique]
coin j'ai tellement hâte et tellement
peur en même temps mais j'ai surtout
[Musique]
hâte de quoi se changer les idées après
des jours à monter et à démonter des
stands dans les
supermarchés
[Musique]
ah c'était tellement génial oh mon dieu
formidable je voudrais être un
poisson je pense que j'étais faite pour
vivre sous l'eau comme une
sirène dans un an ou de la famille songe
à se poser trouver une école primaire
pour leur fille le van ce sera juste
pour les
vacances
quand nous aurons une maison dans le
futur on aura toujours un
van et on s'y sentira comme chez
nous on pourra partir sur la route aussi
longtemps qu'on voudra et on aura notre
maison avec nous sauf que tous les soirs
on regardera le coucher du soleil depuis
un endroit
différent depuis notre tournage Coré et
Émilie ont parcouru plus de 3000 km et
traversé 11 États du Nord au Sud de de
l'Amérique toujours en pratiquant du
yoga sur la route ils ont de plus en
plus
[Musique]
d'abonnés dans le désert de la Sira
Nevada en Californie
àanélise les deux retraités barouur
touchent enfin à leur
objectif les fameuses d'une Deka haute
de 200
m un on apprécie tellement plus ces
moments après une vie passée à
travailler dur et parfois quand on y
repense on en
rigole on fera ça tempant qu'on pourra
20 ans peut-être même
30 le phénomène n'en est qu'à ses début
et devrait s'amplifier 10 millions de
foyers américains possèdent déjà leur
Vann prêts à prendre la
route